about a couple of months ago I tweeted
that 25-year-old women were hotter than
35-year-old women and guys that tweet
probably gave me the most like internet
bullying I've ever received in my life
now look I if I say if you can't take
the heat get out of the game so whatever
like it is what it is but these women
posted pictures of me called me ugly and
they just these grown women you know
some were actually quote unquote
traditional
conservatives said they had to prove
their hotness to me so they were posting
their
selfies like I I'm talking like like
women in the conservative movement said
oh my gosh Pearl I'm I'm 26 and she was
maybe 36 37 Pearl thinks she's hotter
than today I need to wake up and prove
my hotness to Twitter